a story in five words
here's a story in five words most
americans seize the day jerry a new poll
shows that two-thirds of americans have
a carpe diem or seize the moment
attitude
do you live this way okay so i was
completely confused by the story because
i thought sees the day meant take
advantage of all the opportunities that
you're come your way and do what you can
to make yourself and your world better
but no
it's advocating day drinking as far as i
can tell you it's all about like making
yourself feel better and self-care and i
would so i remain confused but i'm not
surprised that a lot of people who were
probably under the age of 40 answered oh
yeah i definitely seized the day one of
the things i said julie is that sense of
pandemic in order to make yourself feel
better and feel like you're really
living as you do a lot of online
shopping
i did that before the panda because
nonsense and you know the the the
percentage of 25
you know drinking more choosing your
favorite beverage i've been doing that
since i was 16.
so like the pandemic has not changed my
life whatsoever other than the fact that
it made me enjoy the fact that i got to
social distance for two years because i
have always done that but normally it's
good to be rude now i'm just following
the law exactly joey how do you live
your life do you seize the day
one day at a time man i'm thankful to be
here you know and a more serious note
gratitude you know
always used to call my house like my
fortress of solitude because i i put
everything i needed there and but sure
it's my fortress of gratitude like i
just i'm so thankful to be alive not
just because i survived something that
should have killed me but because in
doing so um i was reminded of how
blessed i am not just to have you know
my my beautiful family and those
blessings but just to be born in this
country yeah now with that being said
the reason why these youngsters are
living carpe diem let me tell you
something if the government was about to
pay off half my student loans i'd be
taking spring break and combo too like
i mean
there is no better time in the history
of ever to be young and broke than in
the united states right now because to
buy your vote the government will do
anything
despite what jimmy said in the green
room we are glad you're here
[Laughter]
jimmy do you enjoy life's pleasures more
post-pandemic
no actually no i used to day drink more
when i was younger but
my taxi passengers hated it
no i i definitely think i came into this
with the same attitude i come from a
really fun family
and i've always looked at life like
we're all in the fun business to get
seriously to be serious for a second if
you die tomorrow you're not going to
wish you got on one more twitter fight
you know you know we had a good time
listen to a song you like data food you
liked so that's always been my mentality
and that's why i really didn't feel the
journey from where i started to where i
am because i was too busy just enjoying
it like really when i was in a cab and
getting cut off and shot at i'd be like
oh i love this song you know what i mean
and i'm not even kidding like that's my
only secret sauce in life i tell you
that all the time if you look at life
like you're a dog with a job you ever
gone to the airport seen a dog he's
always wagging his tail
he can't believe they're counting on him
to save the plane
that's me
every day
every day
beautifully said
don't go away we'll be right back
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else